مساء الخير
6 مايو 2013
الادانات الصينيه لما تعتبره انتهاك
الامريكيه لسيادتها في مياه بحر الصين
الجنوبي الامريكان يقولون ان لا لانديه
السياده الصينيه
واننا نعتبر يصفوننا من نفس المياه
الدوليه التي اعتدنا ان نعبر منها على
مدار عشرات السنوات والصينيون يريدون ان
هذا كان في الماضي اما الان فقد اصبح ل
بحر الصين الجنوبي صاحب وهذا الصاحب هو
انا او نحن الصين الحقيقه ان الامريكان
والصينيين تواجهها على يعني صعد او على
جبهات كثيره سياسيه وديبلوماسيه واقتصاديه
لكن الصدام العسكري بين الدولتين لا يتم
الا على جبهه واحده وهو جبهه البحر الصيني
كان وفي عشان يفهم خطوره المساله واللي
بيخلي كان البحر الصين الجنوبي اه قضيه
توتر ومنطق التوتر متكرره في كل نشرات
الاخبار بشكل شبه اسبوعي لازم لفهم
الخلفيه ربما يكون المدخل اسهل ان احنا
نعرف فين هو بحر الصين الجنوبي اساسا بحر
الصين الجنوبي من اسلوب يقع جنوب الصين
وهو جزء من المحيط الهادي اللي البحر
مساحته حوالي ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه كيلومتر
مربع نشاط مجموعه من الدول المشكله
الاساسيه انه في حوالي مئات الجزر يعني
مئات الجزر والندوات الصخريه والشعب
المرجانيه والمناطق الضحله وبكل هذه
المناطق هي محل نزاع الدول المتشاطئه على
بحر الصين الجنوبي اللي هي الصين الطيران
والفلبين وفي اثنين واندونيسيا وماليزيا
وسلطنه بروناي ال الحادث
الخلافات بالدول ليست جديده مئات السنوات
ولكن لانه هذه الجزر بطبيعتها لم تكن
ماهوله وغير صالحه للسكن اساسا فكان
الخلاف ب يقتصر على حق الصيت وبالتالي ظل
الخلافات موجوده مناوشات هنا مناوشات هناك
ولكن دون وجود خلافات كبيره الدليل على
ذلك انه حتى العام الف وتسع مائه وسته
واربعين لم تلق اي من هذه الدول لاحتلال
اه اي من هذه الجزر اللي موجوده لكن بدات
الكردي او مياه بحر الصين الجنوبي تكتسب
اهميه تدريجيه بدايه من نهايه الحرب
العالميه الثانيه
وزادت هذه الاهميه في السبعينات مع ظهور
البطوله ثم زالت الاهميه مع اكتشاف الغاز
واصبحت ال اهميه قصوى على الاقل لدى الصين
مع شعوبها الى اه يعني اه قمه اه يعني اه
قوتها الاقتصاديه في السنوات الاخيره هو
اي اهميه بحر الصين الجنوبي بالنسبه للصين
وبالنسبه الامريكان وللدول اللي موجوده
عليها مبدئيا من حيث الثروات تقديرات
وكاله المعلومات الطاقه وكانت معلومات
الطاقه الامريكيه بتقول انه ت قدراتها ان
في من حيث ال بتقول في 11 مليار برميل
بترول تحت مياه البحر وفي جهه اخرى وتضاعف
الرقم اثنين وعشرين مليار برميل بترول
طبعا بتقدر ت مبدئيا
وفي غير تقديرات الامريكان ان في 190
مليون قدم مكعب من الغاز المياه الى جده
وجهات اخرى بتعتقد ان الكميه لن تقل عن
وتسعين مليون قدم مكعب من الغاز
اضف الى كده انه بحر الصين الجنوبي واحد
من اكثر الاماكن اهميه كمصدر للاسماك
ويمثل من اثناشر من 10 ل 12 في المائه من
كميه الاسماء اللي بيتم استاذ ها في
العالم كله خلاف الاهميه لنا ان تهدي ال
يعني هو كموقع بيمر منه تقديرات ال ال
البيت الابيض انه حجم التجاره اللي مرت من
بحر الصين الجنوبي ومعظمها من
من الغرب الى الشرق ومن الشرق الى الغرب
باكثر من خمسه مليون دولار في الساعه
تكلمت في 2017 حل نهائي جدا من التجاره
بيمر عبر هذه المنطقه بل ان تقديرات ال
ايضا
وكانت الوكاله الامريكيه ل معلومات الطاقه
انه بحلول سنه خمسه وعشرين يعني بعد ست
ساعات تسعين في المائه من كل التقى الفندق
في منطقه الشرق الاوسط سوف تتجه لاسيا
وبالتالي سوف تعبر ايضا من منطقه بحر
الصين الجنوبي ولذلك فالصراع قائم على
اشده في منطقه بحر الصين الجنوبي
الخلاف الاول ال ال حضراتكم ما كانش فيه
خلاف كبيره خلاف بدا بدايه يشتد من
السبعينات وفي السبعينات بدات الصين تظهر
العين الحمراء الى جيرانها واذا بالقوه
العسكريه الفيتناميين من بعض القدر التي
كانوا قد استولوا عليها ثم ازاحت الاسطول
الفلسطيني ثم بدات تضع يدها على تسعين في
المائه من الجزر كل دوله من الدول التي
ذكرتها
امكانياتها القانونيه والتاريخيه علشان
تؤكد ادعاءاتها بان لها جزء من جزر بحر
الصين الجنوبي اللي هي المئات لكن الصين
ينتظرها او تقول انا انتو كل واحد فيكم
بيقول عمليه قطعه من هذه الجزر وانا بقول
ان بحر الصين الجنوبي كله للصحفيين وعندها
خريطه مشهوره اسمها تم اين
دا عباره عن خط كده مكون من تسعه يعني
قطعه يعني وان التسعه دول تقريبا بيغطوا
بحر الصين الجنوبي كل وبدون انديه هي
حدودنا في بحر الصين الجنوبي هي طبعا على
عكس المعتاد في الاعراف الدوليه الدول
بتقبل احداثيات دقيقه
عشان تثبت حقها في مياه دوليه الصين بتقدم
خطوط عامه وبتقول في الوقت المناسب ان
اقدم الاحداثيات الدقيقه لكن انا لست في
عجله من امرها الى الامريكان هم اللي
مستعجلين والامريكان مشرف في المساله سوف
اتفاهم مع ايران الكرام بيقولوا انه تفاهم
الصينيين يتم عبر الحوار غير متكامل ان
القوه الصغير ضخمه جدا
العسكريه والسياسيه والاقتصاديه بتخلي
الحوار متكافئ فيتنام لجات الى التحكيم
الدولى فى 2016
وحكم لها بان لها ان ليس للصين حق في يعني
السيطره على قدر امامها
على ما اذكر
لكن الصينيين لم يهتموا بالحكم الدولي
وهما اساسا لا يثق في الاسس اللي بتقام
عليها او تؤسس عليها التحكيم الدولي
والواقع الان
بحكم الامر الواقع الصينيون يسيطرون على
كامل بعد الصين الكوبي تقريبا الامريكان
مش قادرين يتقبل الوضع ده لانه الامريكان
كانوا وربما لغايه فتره قريبه جدا ومع ان
اسطول موجود في منطقه البحر الصين الجنوبي
وفي المحيط الهادي
حرب العالميه الثانيه
ويشعر انه اذا تركوا المجال للصينيين سوف
تحول سوف يتحول بحر الصين الجنوبي الى
محاور صينيه ما يهدد مصالحهم بشده ولذلك
يصر الامريكان وبعض الحلفاء في العبور
كما اعتادوا ان يمروا في نفس المياه الى
الصين بتقول مياه خاصه بها المساله قد
يؤدي الى احتكاكات البنتاغون نشر او
النيويورك تايمز نقلت عن البنتاغون ان من
مواجهه غير منها او خطره ما بين القوات
الصينيه والقوات الامريكيه اخطر هذه
المواجهات كان في 18 سبتمبر 2013
وحصل في هذا اليوم ان سفينه حربيه صينيه
تكتب سفينه حربيه امريكيه علشان تمنعها من
العبور في مياه الاقليميه
وكانت النتيجه السفينتين كاد ان يصطدم
وتوقف فقط على بعد حوالي ثلاثه وثلاثين
متر فقط لا غير
المساله ايضا ليست جديده تمتد لسنوات في
الفين وواحد على سبيل المثال حدثت مناوشات
مرين طائره تجسس امريكيه ايضا في بحر
الصين الجنوبي وما بين مقاتله الصينيه
وقتل التيار الصيني و توترت العلاقه بين
البلدين على مدار شهور قائد الاسطول
قائد القياده الامريكيه في منطقه الان او
منطقه المحيط الهندي
الهادي بيقول في الكونغرس او ال في
الكونغرس في سنه 2017 انه الصينيين الان
اصبحوا يسيطرون تماما على منطقه البحر
الصمد الصين الجنوبي في كل السيناريوهات
مع هذا السيناريو الحرب وسيناريو الحرب
ايضا ليس مطروحا الان لكن حتى السيناريو
الحرب اللي هو بيقولوا نحنا ممكن يبلينا
في الافضليه الامريكان ليس واثقين ان لهم
الغلبه فيه في حدود لانها تقديرات
البنتاكون بتقول انه في مقابل
317 قطعه حربيه وغواصه الصينيه الامريكان
بيمتلك وابت ان ثلاثه وثمانين فقط يعني
الصليبيه
317 قطعه حربيه في مقابل مائتين ثلاثه
وثمانين قطعه
للامريكان معنى كده انه فيه تفوق عدد
الصينيين
وتقديراتهم انه في سنه 2017 تقديرات
البنتاغون اسف اقتراب البنتاغون في 2009
17 ان الصينيين بحلول 2025 يعني بعد ست
ساعات يتفوق عليهم من حيث عدد القطع بنسبه
ثلاثين في المائه وان الصينيين س يمتلكون
يمتلك الان حاملتي الطائرات سوف يمتلكون
الضعف اربع حاملات طائرات وبالتالي اصبح
الامريكان شديد القلق على انه التفوق ذاهب
في الاتجاه الصيني
في ضابط مخابرات في الاسطول الامريكي اللي
موجود في بحر الصين
الجنوبي او بمعني اصح في
المحيط الهادي والمحيط الهندي كتب مقاله
نشرت في كرمال الاسطول الامريكي اسمها
كيف خسرنا الحرب في المحيط الهادي ال
المقال كتبوا بصيغه تخيليه بتخيل انه هو
بيكتب المقاربه سنه الفين وخمسه وعشرين
وانه هو كضربه الحرب
برقيات الى رؤساء واخلاص هذا المقال
التخيلي بيقول انه الصينيين ان الامريكان
اخطاوا خطا فادحا بانهم لم يضربوا
الصينيين او لم
على قدرتهم حين كانت تفوق لصالحهم لانهم
تركوا المجال حتى سيطره الصينيون على
الحرب وبالتالي نحن خسرنا الحرب لاننا لم
نتحرك ضد الصينيين في الوقت المناسب يقصد
الوقت المناسب اللي هو 2017 2018 والان
وهم لا يتحركون
الامريكان يشعرون بالخطر من سنه الفين
وعشره بشكل واضح ايام اداره اوباما وعلشان
كده بيسير وعمليات اسمها عمليات حريه
الملاحه هم وحلفائهم اللي هما يتحدث فيها
الصينيين و بيعبروا
لكن ال ال الاشكاليه اللي بيكون ان
الصينيين بيكفوا يوم بعد يوم وجودهم في
بحر السن القانوني يعني غير سيطرتهم على
الجزر المختلفه هناك في بحر الصين الجنوبي
وما كان الصناعيه في مطارات حربيه
والهيمنه يعني هاربر او
انه يستقبلوا فيها سفرهم العسكريه
وبالتالي بيعزز وجودهم يوم بعد يوم
الحقيقه انه الصراع العسكري بين البلدين
مش مختصره منطقه البحر السني كانوا تموز
كمال على بعد مسافه مش رهيبه او مش بعيده
في منطقه ما يعرف بحر الصين الشرقي لان
فيه خلافات ايضا على مجموعه من ال كثر ما
بين الصينيين واليابانيين
والتوتر الموجود والامريكان المطاردين
ايضا في هذه المنطقه والصراع في المنطقتين
جزء من صراع واسعه جدا ما بين الصينيين
والامريكان للسيطره على كل الملا مجاري
الملاحيه المهمه جدا في العالم وهذا يقتضي
منا حلقه اخرى ان شاء الله اشكركم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]